si una persona se rompe el tobillo y los
huesos ya no se alinean entre sí es
posible que el médico deba realizar un
procedimiento quirúrgico para volver a
posicionar los y fijarlos
el tobillo es la articulación que
conecta la pierna y el pie la
articulación del tobillo incluye los dos
huesos inferiores de la pierna
denominados tibia y peroné- y el hueso
del tobillo denominado astrágalo
juntos los extremos de la tibia y del
peroné crean una mortaja o ranura para
el astrágalo que forma la parte inferior
de la articulación del tobillo los
tejidos denominados ligamentos y
tendones son el soporte de los huesos
del tobillo los ligamentos conectan
huesos con huesos y los tendones
conectan los músculos a los huesos
la articulación del tobillo permite que
el pie se mueva hacia arriba y hacia
abajo
las lesiones de tobillo suelen ocurrir
durante actividades deportivas caídas o
accidentes automovilísticos el tipo más
común de fractura de tobillo se produce
cuando el pie gira hacia adentro y el
tobillo rota hacia afuera
si la fractura es estable las piezas
óseas quedan alineadas en su posición
normal en cualquier tipo de fractura se
puede romper más de un hueso
en una fractura desplazada las piezas
óseas ya no se alinean
si el hueso traspasa la piel se la
conoce como fractura compuesta o abierta
además de huesos rotos el tobillo puede
sufrir un esguince esto significa que se
han estirado desgarrado los ligamentos
si el tobillo está muy hinchado el
cirujano puede retrasar un procedimiento
quirúrgico para permitir que la
hinchazón baje durante este tiempo el
cirujano puede poner una férula en el
tobillo para proporcionar apoyo
además puede recomendar elevar el
tobillo por encima del nivel del corazón
y aplicarle hielo
para tratar una fractura de tobillo
estable el médico puede ingresar la
pierna o colocar una bota para que el
tobillo no se mueva y los huesos puedan
sanar juntos
las fracturas desplazadas y compuestas
con múltiples huesos rotos y ligamentos
desgarrados pueden requerir un
procedimiento quirúrgico el
procedimiento quirúrgico más común para
reparar una fractura de tobillo
desplazada se llama reducción abierta
con fijación interna para empezar el
cirujano hace una incisión sobre el área
de la fractura el cirujano abre el
tobillo para ver las piezas óseas
y las alinea de nuevo entre sí
se usa una placa y tornillos para
mantenerlos alineados se pueden insertar
tornillos adicionales a través de otra
incisión para mantener otros fragmentos
de la fractura en su lugar si se dañan
gravemente los ligamentos que sostienen
la tibia y el peroné juntos el cirujano
debe colocar un tornillo a través de
ambos huesos o bien puede colocarse un
dispositivo de sutura a través de ambos
huesos cualquiera de estos dispositivos
ayuda a mantener unidos los huesos
mientras sanan los ligamentos al final
del procedimiento
el cirujano cerrará toda incisión de la
piel con puntos de sutura